bonjour 0 mena bonjour monsieur viol
tombe on joue aussi à la population du
nord caraïbes et particulièrement aux
deux génies dungey vous êtes le maire de
français denis merci d'être dansante à
10 pour le nord caraïbe
on va le dire c'est la loi des séries un
accident avec un camion toupie qui a
paralysé la route nationale 2 durant
plus de 6 heures c'était à fond là et
vendredi dernier et puis hier encore un
camion de carburant qui se rend vers
cette fois ci vers la distillerie nghi
son au carbet deux accidents henry
romana qui viennent démontrer la
fragilité et la vulnérabilité de ce
secteur géographique
en tous les cas du moment qu'ils
accident il ya matière pensez vous savez
que dans une semaine des accidents
surtout disons de véhicules poids lourds
je pense qu'il faut se poser des
questions sur la nature des ces droits a
appelé national du il est vrai que s'ils
voient que le nom au karibe a été
délaissée pendant un certain temps je
pense que de nos jours il va falloir
travailler dans cette direction à savoir
améliorer les axes routiers de ces
secteurs qui finalement qui pourra
peut-être un pc l'économie un parce que
vous savez dans le nord caraïbes a été
laissée aux comptes pendant quelques
temps alors il ya plusieurs
il ya plusieurs choses à relever dans
votre premier propose romana tout
d'abord cette réaction commune de
plusieurs maires 1 celui du prêcheur
celui de saint pierre celui du
morne-rouge madame jenny dulys du mort
de verre
ces maires qui sont montés au créneau
pour demander d'urgence une rencontre
avec cap nord la communauté
d'agglomération ainsi que l'assemblée de
martinique est ce que vous voulez qu'est
ce que vous attendez de ces deux
structures il comptait ce que nous
appelons dans des instances compétentes
c'est du sang de deux pencher sans
véritable disons regard du secteur no
caraïbes pourrait améliorer les
conditions
vous savez que si will en voiture ça
fait partie des liberté d'aller et venir
que nous constatons depuis un certain
temps que nous sommes sujette à des
difficultés de circulation
je prends par exemple le secteur de
france denis nous avons là d une là d
une qui est en piteux état où certains
virages mérine nécessite une
rectification une amélioration c'est à
l'époque où ses voûtes ont été
construites à la mer avec à l'aide de
pelles et de pioches
maintenant nous avons quand même des
engins de terrassement c'est quand même
une opportunité pour c'est quoi
exactement qu'on améliore l'existant ou
qu'on réfléchisse à un autre schéma de
nos structures dans un premier temps
c'est ce serait d'améliorer l'existant
et qui dit qu'à améliorer en aux
héritiers aussi c'est jouer la sécurité
moi je pense que je reste toujours de ce
que je connais pertinemment s'est assagi
la dune est ce que vous pensez que de
nos jours qu'un véhicule de transport de
personne ne peut pas transité par cette
route d une ce sont des des des
infarctus et l'alimentation d'eau sur
romana commente acquis c'est la faute à
qui aujourd'hui les maires du nord
caraïbes se réveille brusquement parce
qu'il ya eu coup sur coup deux accidents
non c'est la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase
par rapport aux combis au quotidien
parce que l'on imaginé tout simplement
que camions qui tombait pas côté
distillerie né soyez il est tombé à boca
qui satisfaite mais écoutez vous savez
déjà c'est un camion qui transportait
des matières dangereuses
vous savez le carburant c'est un liquide
inflammable castrais maman dangereux et
déjà qui se puisse se répandre équipe et
prendre la direction des cours d'eau
même la mer vous savez quand la mère ou
le cours d'eau est imbibé de ce
carburant il faut dépolluer et ça
nécessite aussi beaucoup de travaux bon
les oiseaux mans que nous avons les
sapeurs pompiers qui ont pris les choses
en main
qui ont fait qu'est mis en place un
périmètre de sécurité ou en cas
d'explosion sait jamais pour lui amener
les usagers mais je pense que je
revienne coup les dizaines de milliers
d'habitants du nord caraïbes sont
paralysés par ils sont paralysés
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une seule voix
celle à la nationale 2 où la nationale 3
c'est à dire la nationale 2 qui relie
prêcheur fort de france et la nationale
3 qui relie qui parle depuis ajoupa
bouillon et qui arrive à fort de france
en passant par la trace moi je pense que
il faut penser et rapidement jeudi dans
un premier temps a procédé à
l'amélioration de ces dites voir ne
serait-ce que les landes à deux voies
sud circulation de caunes élargissement
niveau en élargissement des voies et
surtout profond soudani surtout les
lèvres l'élargissement disons des
ouvrages hydrauliques
parce que je pense que c'est
inacceptable que un véhicule de
transport de personne ne paie pas
transité par le fonds se donner de soi
surtout que vous le maire de fos et
dénis faisais mes ateliers vous et
combien de communes autour de vous nous
sommes et nous nous ajustons avec neuf
communes fonctionner pourquoi ce sera
une petite commune de produits et sur le
court central sur le baril et le baril
sont quelques uns disons du nord je
pense qu'il faut prévoir déjà dans un
premier temps apporter quand même une
amélioration sur les axes routiers
existants et à l'avenir voir des
désagréments parce que je parle du
cagire nouvelle route
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas parce que nous
avons quand même des gens là il ya le
progrès qu'il a avec des engins de
terrassement avec des engagements sous
ie qui peuvent quand même coupé il ya
des endroits boisés sessou du super de m
souvent ce que promettent les maires
lorsqu'ils sont campagne électorale et
nous allons presque construits nouvelles
routes pour désenclaver on à part qu'on
a vu sa maison mère a mené 3 il a même
ans j'avais la vue ça à chaud et puis
une fois qu'on est élu on oublie ça nous
on en oublie par qui seront très bas en
basset
kiss and commander la 7e la prise de
commande actuellement c'est d'avoir un
regard sous l'axé les axes routiers du
nord caraïbes ou ne serait-ce que de 2,2
d'améliorer les conditions de
circulation et surtout aussi de prévoir
de maintenir ce qu'avaient prévu les
ancêtres mais je vois que campoli qu'il
nous avons nous autres qui nous relient
vers saint joseph et comme par
enchantement
cette voie est devenu nout forestière
mais sans panneau soit aussi
juridiquement il va falloir voir un
petit peu le contexte juridique duzan de
cette voie qui relie à certain nombre de
choses à faire et puis ya d'autres
enjeux pour monsieur romana vous
demandez par exemple la septième de
réfléchir aux autorités quatre morts ces
thèmes de réfléchir à peut-être de
nouvelles infrastructures routières
parce qu'il ya un hors jeu économique et
aujourd'hui vous êtes un élu de
proximité
vous savez que l'argent est de plus en
plus rares et vous demandez peut-être
des interventions dans un secteur qui se
barre des 10 qui perd ses habitants même
même que l'argent ira vous avez monsieur
verte on vous le savez tous les marines
que le savent il ya des gens des fonds
européens qui ce qu'ils repartent vers
vers bruxelles qui n'ont pas utilisé je
pense que il souhaitant qu'un au mitan
des véritables projets en place et
qu'ils soient financés par l'europe et
par exemple à cet âge là pour ça dépose
un projet mais contre nous travaillons
nous les met au dessus du secteur
nous travaillons ensemble à abobo dans
cette direction est ce qu'avec les
maires que vous avez vous êtes concerter
avec certains maires au cours de nos
cours du week-end pour sortir ce
communiqué est ce que vous avez envie de
vous asseoir tous ensemble non le
regarder cette partie de la martinique
et puis d'établir un nouveau schéma
routier faire des propositions vous clés
en main par exemple à d'autres instances
puisque bel apparat fait assez vite
nous travaillons dans cette direction et
nous avons
nous avons nous avons l'habitude de nous
réunir pour nous pencher un petit peu
sur le devenir du nord caraïbes ne
serait ce que sur le plan économique
est-ce que vous pensez que monsieur v
ème temps tous les habitants du secteur
et pendant la même direction la
direction du centre c'est à dire ou ce
secteur a subi un exode considérable par
rapport à l'économie qui a été laissé
pour compte
c'est un secteur qui est porteur qui a
quand même des atouts et considère agile
qui fait qu'ils franchissent passé mais
qui fragilise et fragile parce que ce
qui se passe fragile pourquoi parce
qu'il ya la houle
il ya autre chose mais on ne prend pas
le temps de jeter un regard particulier
sur ce secteur à 20 ne serait-ce que de
maîtriser la démographie parce que on a
subi l'exode
tout le monde est parti vers le centre
et maintenant vers le sud
le nom n'est pas développé on a eu terre
la subit en délaissement de la part
disons des autorités compétentes
vous avez parlé de la houle c'est un
risque majeur oui il faut il voir mon
temple et qui peut se révéler oui elles
viendront oui à l'avancé les vertus
actions dia là où il ya la montagne
pelée les risques volcaniques et en
prend volcanique it qui est mis en place
qui a été élaboré par les maires du
secteur supposant que monsieur le plan
nous avons une éruption volcanique
ce sera la pagaille comme en fera et
pour évacuer les habitants du secteur
et puis sans oublier l'autoroute
maritime tout le long du no ko et bien
des pontons qui sont qui ne sont pas
utilisés et parker la desserte maritime
il a fallu aussi le point d'entente
merci d'avoir avec nous envient romana
merde foncé denis on a parlé du
désenclavement du nord caraïbes non je
vous en prie dieu merci c'est moi qui
vous remercie monsieur vers le bas